Belgrade Sarajevo Pristina and Skopje in
recent weeks all four have been ranked
in the top 10 list of the world's most
polluted cities January has been a
suffocating ordeal for the residents of
the Balkans
we are worried for the whole of mankind
this is not good but Sarajevo then
Belgrade and all of the cities it is
polluted because of cars and bad fuel
coal and lignite a recent UN report
agreed finding that more than 60% of
people here rely on coal and firewood
stoves to heat their homes 20% of the
region's premature deaths were directly
linked to chronic air pollution the
Bosnian capital Sarajevo sits in a
valley ringed by high mountains most of
the past week pollution in the form of
microscopic airborne particles has been
at least twice and sometimes eight times
higher than the EU safe limit do you see
we can hardly breathe when we go out
it's especially hard for patients with
heart and lung problems sometimes you
can't even walk on the street even with
a scarf on with suffocating in the
bosnian town of Tuzla this week carrying
banners saying we want to breathe
hundreds protested their anger at
government inaction
the local authorities tell us stories
about some nebulous temperature
inversion and the like but we all know
that the basic cause of pollution in
this city is particle pollution from
individual heating stoves the city is
simply not investing I came here to
support these protests and to finally
motivate people to enforce a change to
show that they care about this city and
about breathing with full lungs
governments and local authorities often
downplay the issue some politicians
refer to it as choking season simply
typical for the time of year this year
though campaigners are rejecting that
narrative like never before and
demanding clean energy be made more
accessible that older polluting vehicles
should be banned and regulations on
industry emissions and power plants
and all that requires money investment
and with impeccable timing the European
Union last month announced a new Green
Deal fund promising 1.1 trillion dollars
of investment in the Western Balkans it
can't come soon enough
halt Brennan al-jazeera Jelena glue
Shack joins us live now from the Serbian
capital Belgrade and of course you are
in one of the cities that's been
suffering from these dangerous levels of
smog in recent days what's it like over
there just just describe to us that the
conditions you can actually see the air
there that's the problem and tonight
it's even clearer the night before you
couldn't even see those building there
is no problem you're just across the
street but you couldn't see this
building that's why the protest was held
here in Belgrade organized by initiative
don't drown the Belgrade this is a group
of citizens who are trying to warn
motorists about the air quality in
Belgrade and they came out with some
short terms and long terms measures for
that problem and they wanted from the
government to adopt those measures as
soon as possible without any delay first
of all they want to be informed on daily
basis about the air quality and then
they want transformation of public
transport so the number of cars could be
reduced they're also very very active in
promoting alternative way of transport
like cycling or walking and of course
the big issue here is a way of heating
last research here in the Balkans shows
that 9 out of 10 people feels that
pollution is a problem in their
community but they don't feel like they
can do anything about it
and this protesters should make some
difference about it we've been speaking
about there being this problem
with winter smog but given the the fact
that obviously we have this pollution
issue and the government hasn't been
doing very much these are some of the
most polluted cities in Europe is this
something that people are actually
experiencing all year round is it
getting worse oh well sorry ever have
this problem or during the whole year
and Belgrade is more connected to the
winter when we are talking about this
this problem and the really problem is
in communication between the
government's and the citizens both in
Boston Herzegovina and in Serbia for
example here in Belgrade the president
of Serbia days after the very polluted
air here here in Belgrade ask where is
the Minister of Environmental Protection
where is he is he alive is he going to
say something is he going to do
something and this Minister should hold
the press conference today but he
canceled it and in meanwhile the Serbian
president said that this pollution is a
result of bigger standard here in Serbia
so everyone can afford to drive the car
so that's why the air is polluted so
this kind of comments make people more
even more angry so the news from the
government is that prime minister said
that Serbian government should
coordinate all organization involved in
air protection during the days they're
coming so we should get some more
informations about that thank you
appreciate it
yelena cliché joining us there from the
Serbian capital Belgrade